ja leute wie fängt man so ein video an
wie begonnen
wie beginnt man diese neue äre
eigentlich noch viel zu früh ist wenn
wir mal ehrlich sind wir kleinen
schweinchen habt schon auf instagram
dafür bestimmt dass ich wieder anfangen
adventskalender auszupacken im september
aber ich habe heute gesehen dass
supermärkte schon weihnachtssüßigkeiten
verkaufen und ganz ehrlich das was die
können kann ich schon lange also geht es
jetzt los mit 1 kalender nummer 1 in
2020 mein erster adventskalender ist der
musste einfach sein ich benutze als
irgendeine aufbewahrungs kiste einfach
nur damit es mich immer daran erinnern
wird wird hessen heute den harry potter
adventskalender
ich habe letztes jahr schon zwei
adventskalender von harry potter
ausgepackt einmal ein mit maker für den
ich extra nach london gefahren bin und
ein pop sondern so ein kalender wo ich
weiß nicht gerade wie diese kleinen
figuren heißen pops glaube ich ich
glaube diese box und dieser
adventskalender ist gefüllt mit 24
magical gifts mir ist ein paar tagen
aufgefallen ist geht bald wieder los mit
den adventskalendern also wollte ich
einfach nur gucken welche es dieses jahr
geben wird und ob es schon welche gibt
im september und dann gab es den real
onlineshop wir wollen hier korrekt sein
deswegen sage ich euch natürlich den
preis 40 euro 99 eine sache fand ich
komisch das ist zwar auf der real seite
verkauft worden aber es ging über den
horror shop keine ahnung warum in little
fun fact dieses jahr hat noch nicht mal
richtig angefangen und wir bewegen uns
schon mit 180 km/h in richtung weihnacht
seit ich bin ehrlich mit euch ich liebe
die weihnachtszeit ihr wisst es deswegen
bin ich darüber nicht so traurig
trotzdem ist es ein komisches gefühl
dass dieses jahr gefühlt fast zu ende
ist ein wichtiges event kommt aber noch
mein geburtstag am 9 9
danach kann auch halloween und
weihnachten kommen damit habe ich kein
problem
wir starten
türchen nummer 1 diesmal habe ich ja gar
keine ahnung was drin sein könnte
deswegen bin ich ein bisschen aufgeregt
aber ich hoffe dass es 40 99 wert ist
nummer eins das ist natürlich nummer
eins drin socken ein magic sox
dadurch dass jetzt erst der herbst kommt
finde ich das mega kugeln harry potter
hat für mich auch immer extrem so ein
herbst feeling ich kann nicht sagen
warum vielleicht weil diese filme man im
herbst tönen stattfinden die ersten
zumindest es ist ein superstart ja
leider liegt hier noch ein zweiter
gegenstand drin aber vielleicht checken
wir noch woher da ist die nummer zwei
ich glaube das ist türchen nummer zwei
da war nämlich nix drin dadurch dass ich
ihnen ja nur teste finde ich das nicht
so schlimm aber wenn ich mir vorstelle
dass ich in der adventszeit dann so in
einem tütchen nichts und niemanden so 2
dann ist irgendwie blöd kann einer in
den kommentaren sagen was das ist ich
habe pins noch nie so richtig verstanden
deswegen ist okay
türchen nummer 3 von yahoo wir müssen
uns 41 99 namen harry bitte mach nicht
den mp nummer vier
ich hoffe dass es die nummer 4 und ich
habe jetzt nichts falsches rausgezogen
eine kette mit den heiligtümern des
todes also ist jetzt nicht die beste
qualität das ist denke ich schon ein
leid ich war wirklich sehr gerne bei den
handys tickern war ich nicht so
überzeugt aber hier ist ein knoten das
hogwarts wappen als jedem urteil zu
ihren boards oberteil machen bis die
qualität
die qualität ist gut und jetzt kommen
wir zum nikolaustag ich weiß nicht wie
sehr der nikolaustag international
gefeiert wird deswegen kann sein dass
drin ist
hauptsache das nur warner brothers
copyright siegel drauf für dieses symbol
ein stempel everybody
das ist ein stempel wir sind ein türchen
nummer 7 es wird noch besser es wird
noch besser ich glaube daran natürlich
in 7
ich meine es waren 40 euro und keine 70
use only want for christmas ist der
schnaps und ein von miss riesling
gestrickter pulli und ein kühlschrank
magnet aber auch hier müssen das sind
das sind hochwertige sachen nummer 8
noch einen pin weil da kenne ich jetzt
was da drauf ist ramadan war das
vielleicht ein ist das vielleicht der
maler ich kann mich erinnern wie das
tier bei hubble papis aber das ist
glaube ich hoffe passt und hier haben
wir raven chlor das ist dann gleich
wieder raus zum teil dann kannst du dein
happel paar freunden den geben und ich
als raven klar behalte den pin nummer 9
ein pin kann man sich an rucksack machen
nummer 10
das finde ich gut frau
one for christmas es ist so gut sieht es
halt so und es tesa band aus papier was
du irgendwo draufkleben kannst und dann
hast du das also es hat so eine schöne
optik wenn man jetzt ein weihnachtsbrief
schreibt oder so oder ein fotoalbum hat
dann kann man das so zur weihnachtszeit
rein kleben ist wieder leer leider ist
wieder durch gerutscht weil der aber
ganz ehrlich man stellt sich ja so ein
kalender auch oder hängt ihn sich an die
wand man legt ihnen ja nicht die ganze
zeit so hin und beim transport wird da
auch ihr mann hoch gestellt das heißt
wir uns eigentlich hinkriegen in der
herstellung zu sagen okay die haben
jetzt alles gefüllt wollen wir mal
testen und dann fällt die hälfte raus
und man merkt ohne wir müssen uns etwas
anderes ausdenken haben sie nicht
gemacht weiter geht's türchen nummer 12
[Applaus]
bitte nicht bitte mich bitte nicht das
ist das nicht ein bitte lassen
es ist ein appell passepartout weil ich
kann immer noch nicht sagen
darauf weist mader ich glaube es ist ein
magazin sehr futuristisch aus wer hat
sich das design ausgedacht
beziehungsweise nicht hat und dies teil
nummer 13 nummer 13 ist ein großes
türchen innovations- sehen
ein schlüsselanhänger mit den
heiligtümern des todes braucht das ist
auch wieder mal cool wir machen weiter
mit nummer 15 und willkommen bei der
neuen geld abzocke dieses mal mit harry
potter nummer 16
da hängt oft greengas und was ist da
drin ein anspitzer natürlich weil wir
haben ja gerade haben wir ja bleistifte
bekommen deswegen brauchen wir jetzt in
anspitzer nummer 17
wenn man 17 ist leer nummer 18
credit könnt ihr eure sporthose die
bügeln oder feuer sport t shirt oder
beim sport oder auf der sporthose kommt
es bestimmt gut wenn s drauf geht bis
doch süß ein stempel mit gleis 9 drei
viertel 20
ich habe mich schon gefragt wann der
griffen dort hinkommt hier ist der
gryphon dorthin verließ glaube ich
dürfen doch nummer 21
er trägt die dennoch experte patronen
und ein samuraischwert ein abzug gut
[Musik]
gut helfe ich habe mir so gewünscht ich
habe gedacht es gibt sowie kohlberg und
40 euro wird doppel stimmt irgendwas
brauchbares drin sein ja eine kette
kriege ich schon guten heitz nein und
die socken 22 40 euro
23 wir kriegen hier langsam an die
sachen vor der sita die aus der vita die
auto also wirklich ne also ist offen da
logo sieht zwar aus wie irgendwie von
der biermarke das leben aber das ist
hier wirklich und wie kommen schon zum
letzten türchen das tütchen 24 das schon
wieder irgendwas ausgezogen
münchen 24 wo war denn alles andere drin
also hier ist gerade random diese posse
die hier nicht sehr süß ich brauche
tatsächlich auch solche posten
dankeschön harry was ist denn jetzt hier
alles okay natürlich in 24 befindet sich
erstmals - wahrscheinlich ganz
verrutscht sein natürlich der raven klar
dass raven squad tattoo ist in 24 also
es wirklich eighties der gräfin der
leyen so eine abzocke irgendwelche
bilder
und was gibt's denn noch so eins
überraschung nein bitte nicht
bitte sagt nicht was ist das hässlich
guckt euch ins grübeln kommen weil die
schülerin schlange an die sieht aus wie
dann auch im kinderbuch dieser maler
oder whatever welches tier das ist wo es
der wurst der stolze raven klar komm
zeig mal und das wichtigste des horrors
wappen was mache ich jetzt mit der tour
wollen jetzt wirklich von mir dass ich
so mache das einzige was ich noch machen
kann es so aber wer also das einzige was
ich gerade dachte okay für kleine kinder
verstehe ich irgendwo noch aber kleine
kinder können doch nicht für 40 euro
adventskalender bekommen und ist das was
wir brauchen darüber nicht reden ob dass
der warenwert ist aber es ist schon sehr
enttäuschend
und man muss auch wie bei dem harry
potter kochbuch inoffiziell schreiben
weil das ist inoffiziell das ist nicht
wirklich harry potter gramm
das ist von dieser firma ziele bis die
haben sich die rechte von harry potter
gekauft deswegen dürfen sie unser ding
world drauf machen und haben diesen
adventskalender gemacht sie haben aber
genau das gleiche prinzip angewendet
machen einfach was oft den so oft
magnete außerdem pillen drucken wir auch
etwas und zwei stempel 34 wann nicht
2010 mal diese gummi armreifen beliebt
danke schön klar und so gut angefangen
es ist relativ oder haben also die
sachen kann ich gut leben und die kette
finde ich auch gut an dass raschid der
krieg um punkt vor mir habe ich gefallen
ist
23 hab ich gar nicht ausgepackt
radiergummi
das finde ich nicht so richtig den
trostpreis wer dennoch so hinterher
geworfen wird chocolate frog radiergummi
dankeschön für diesen tollen
adventskalender
ich hoffe ihr seht auch beim nächsten
mal wieder zu wenn es heißt was steckt
wohl im erp adventskalender und macht
erp dieses jahr ein adventskalender da
bin ich noch viel gespannter wenn sie
noch mal einen raushauen werde ich den
auf jeden fall testen schreibt mir gerne
in die kommentare
welche kalender ihr dieses jahr
unbedingt sehen wollen gleich habt ihr
von irgendeinem adventskalender gehörte
total krasses und den ihr unbedingt
ausgepackt sehen wollen es ist immer
noch september 1 bitte schreibt nicht in
die kommentare es ist september vanessa
ich beiße sich september aber soll ich
machen ich liebe einfach adventskalender
und ich liebe die weihnachtszeit und für
mich kann sie nicht früh genug kommen
ich hoffe die adventskalender werden
besser bis dann also mal war
ich habe